qué fue lo que se logró en esta
restauración de los diálogos A qué se
comprometieron las partes
en primer lugar por tenemos un beneficio
que es la suscripción de una declaración
que marca formalmente el reinicio de una
conversación que ya habían sido
interrumpidas en 2018 y eso desde el
punto de vista político diplomático
representa un éxito para quienes tienen
expectativas de que se puedan establecer
una base más sólidas en lo que ha sido
el interrumpido pero muy controvertido
diálogo y mesas para la paz en Colombia
eso sería como el primer beneficio el
segundo es ratificar Quienes son
garantes en este proceso de paz que
siguen siendo fundamentalmente los
mismos aunque han cambiado las
locaciones y han cambiado las
representaciones desde el punto de vista
de Quiénes son los presidentes de los
países garantes fundamentales en este
caso Gustavo Petro en Colombia y Nicolás
Maduro en Venezuela fundamentalmente eso
los otros son muy controvertidos porque
hay muchas expectativas posiciones poco
claras o podríamos decir relativamente
herméticas Pero eso forma parte de
cualquier proceso de paz y mucho más de
la controvertido que va a ser esta etapa
por las partes involucradas algo que
llamó la atención Es que en esta
restauración no se habló de un alto el
fuego entre las partes Pese a que llln
propuso hace poco una tregua es posible
negociar en medio de las posibles
confrontaciones
Sí históricamente eso ha sido posible
decir durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial
mientras había bombardeos y hubo
muchísimas otras actividades militares
inclusive con el lanzamiento de las
bombas nucleares en Hiroshima y nagasaki
se estaban haciendo negociaciones de paz
y subsecuentemente muchos otros
conflictos han sido así no ha habido
interrupción o no se presenta un alto al
fuego de repente cuando se está en la
mesas de negociación puede haber una
declaración temporal porque es exigida
por alguna de las partes a que haya
formalmente una declaración del alto al
fuego y que pueda ser verificado bien
sea por países garantes o por alguna
otra instancia eso todo es posible pero
nada está totalmente afinado en este
momento Bueno y cómo se ve el papel de
Venezuela es decir un país señalado de
dar Refugio integrantes de lln pero que
ahora es sede de los diálogos se puede
considerar Un regreso de esta nación a
la escena diplomática internacional
Sí el gobierno de Nicolás maduro ha
hecho distintos intentos por esa
reinserción más formal llamémoslo así
sobre todo por los efectos que han
tenido las sanciones de los Estados
Unidos y por un cierto bajo perfil de
algunas acciones del punto de vista
regional la entrada de Gustavo Petro
pero también lo que va a ser la futura
censo de Ignacio lulada Silva en el mes
de enero pueden dar un impulso a esa
aparición regional individualmente el
gobierno Nicolás Maduro ha hecho
distintos intentos sin embargo como lo
bien señalaste al inicio es muy polémica
es polarizada cualquier tipo de
información o análisis que se haga sobre
la participación de Venezuela Son puntos
encontrados porque siguen habiendo
dificultades económicas sociales en
Venezuela y sobre todo el tema de la
gobernabilidad y lo que pudiera ser la
participación de los grupos políticos de
oposición en una futura de elección en
Venezuela Y eso sin duda Va a afectar lo
que pudieran ser la los avances o la
visibilidad mediática el impacto que
pudiera tener estas negociaciones de paz